俺えっ
あの
ai 寝具ラリティの話がありましたね
それから
ロボットの話もありました
ロボットと人工知能がとっても進化しているといいます
一機会が人の仕事を奪うと言います
恐ろしいですね
すでに金融取引の7割は人工知能が行ってるんですって
最近では映像や音楽を作る人工知能も現れたと言いますでは
機械が人にとって代わるとして人に残るものは何でしょう
その一つが
スポーツであります
機械と人を融合して誰もが超人になれる
スポーツを作りましょうそれ僕ら超人スポーツと呼んでいます
2020年東京にはオリンピックパラリンピックが開きますそこに向かっての挑戦で
あります
2020年といえばかつてウルトラ q で肉体の退化したケムール人が地球人の若い
肉体を1行ってきました
僕らはデジタル技術で売るとらーに体を強化しておく必要があります時間がありません
んマルクス霊夢さんと言うと
鬱子がいますロンドンパラリンピック2012年の走り幅跳びのゴールドメダリスト
です
義足のジャンパーなんですよ
彼は去年の同一選手権で8m 24センチの記録を叩き出しました
やりすぎたんですかね健常者に向かってしまっただから
ヨーロッパ選手権でからドイツ代表として出られなかったんですよ
でもねこれは2020東京ではパラリンピックの方がオリンピックよりも高得点が出る
その号砲が鳴ったということじゃないですか
義手義足の人に憧れたっていいじゃですか
僕は子供の頃サイボーグ00風いないだ
004アルベルトハインリヒになりただ彼もドイツ人です
女は照準器右手はマシンが左手は種類気になります
運ばれたっていいじゃないですかみんなも当然ですか幼い頃ですね草むらでこうての
サッカー
何かかめはめ波のようなものが出ないかでないかと踏ん張ったことはないですか
こいつらぱレディたフランス人ですけど彼らだって思いは同じはず
何か出したいと思っているこれを実現しましょう
これが長寿スポーツであります僕らはずっと神体の拡張を願ってきました
手足を拡張しようと思って杖をつくって義足を作りました
浮き輪をつくって船を作りました車を作って施工機を飛ばしてロケットを飛ばして遠く
早く行けるようになりました
視聴覚を拡張しようとしてメガネを作って補聴器を作ります
スピーカーをつくって電話をつくって
でテレビをつくってインターネットをつくって投稿早くコミュニケーションができる
ようになりましたこうやって僕らは外へ外へと進退を拡張してきたんですけれども今度
はその拡張した進退に技術を
取り込むことによってわれわれの拡張した神体とは何なのか
それをとというのが超人スポーツであります
ああ
ちょっとちょっと下げていく
noa
新しいスポーツ
例えば水の上を走る
だって女だん
空中で作家をするやってるぜ
サッカーにしろ野球にしろラグビーにしろ
19世紀できたスポーツ農業社会のスポーツであります
20世紀の工業社会ではモータースポーツが出来ましたでは皆さんの[ __ ]だろこの情報
社会です
どんなスポーツたらいいですか
it とかデジタル技術を取り込んでソースねっ
子供でもウサインボルトも勝てるとか
おばあちゃんでも吉田沙保里選手に勝てるとだ
造語も撮りたいですあの僕でも魔球が投げられるようなボールだとか
何 km も酒にある的を遺族アーテルの弓あ
ん
スポーツの楽しみ方も変えたいんですよ例えば
うーん
マラソン大会で
一人ひとりの選手の上に一個一個ドローンを飛ばして自分の見たい選手わかるぞを
止めることができるとかできますよねやりましょう
そういう世界を作ろフクロウと思いまして春に超人スポーツ協会っていう境界を作り
ました
共同代表は3名僕と東京大学の稲見昌彦東京大学の暦本11そこにいろんな人が集まっ
ています
科学者たち脳科学スポーツかなくロボットの技術者
それからゲームのデザ
なうですとかアーティストアスリート思いますそのような方々と一緒にスポーツを作る
実践するそして普及させるという活動をやってんですが目標があります
2020年には超人五種競技世界大会を4オリンピックパラリンピックとともに開き
たいと思っています
競技人口も増やしたいですね今この僕らが超人スポーツピョンでいるものにタッチして
くれたのはまだ千年ぐらいしかいないんですがこれを早く1万倍にして1000万円
くらいまでに広げたいと思っています
あの
いろんな
バックグラウンドを方々座技優木沙々んさんだったり
科学者だったりアーティストだったり
アスリートだったりが集まってみんなでつくるということだったんでしょ
で超人スポーツハッカソンという開きましてでその中で出てきたアイデアったら
競技になりそうなものをいくつか集めましてねこの間
超人スポーツ expo っていうのを開きましたいくつか面白いなので紹介し
ましょう
あのジャンピングシューズっていうのを吐きましてねこれ履けば誰でもそう人になれる
んですよちょっと踏んで言いますよ
えっとその西洋の竹馬みたいに乗りまして
上半身はボールですダフルボールっていうのを身に付けてですねこれ衝撃を吸収するん
ですね
まぁこれで新しい相撲ての開発てっ
重い切りぶつかっても転んでもアン税なのでかなり激しいスポーツになるんですけど
これちょっとコツを会得すると子供でもかなり超人になるのでかなり若い世代に超人に
なってもらいたいなぁと思って期待しています
こいつらが今日時になるわけです
あの馬をですねモーターデバイスにしましてそれで車日はそのこれは暴れるんですそれ
を手綱だけでコントロールしてレースをするというレースキャリイをとっていますベン
ハーに出てくる
古代ローマのあの競技あるじゃないですか
あの人馬一体の協議を人一体に
するというスポーツ今この機会も同時に作っているところなんですけどね
ドッチボールの新しい版プレイヤー1人1人にですね攻撃力と防御力の
その個性を与えておきますよねそのライフポイントを競うというもの
つまりテレビゲームの世界を実際のフィールドに持ってきたと思うんです
こういうゲームとか漫画やアニメといったポップからちゃ
これを技術で実現するって言うのも恭順スポーツのミッションでありましてそこで
デザイナーの卵真ん中のため
もいろんな人たちに張順スポーツなるものをイメージして空想してたくさんイラストを
書いてもらっています
これを技術者たちが現実に実現するという取り組みをやったりします
さて逆に現実の動きをバーチャルのゲームの空間で持って凍ってそういうゲームであり
ます身体を動かすことによってバーチャル空間でかめはめ波のようなものを出して敵と
戦うというそういうやつ
波動と言います
陣取りゲーム実際のフィールドでですねバーチャルな神採りをします
あつこ氏にこう備えられたビーコンに植え付けられた
スマホをタップするとバーチャルな陣地がぽれるというこれもバーチャルとリアルの
融合ですね
日本にはですねだるまさんがころんだというファンタスティックな遊びがあります
えっこあっ動く時は動く止まるときはパシッと泊まらなきゃいけないというのを
松葉杖でつ使ってやりましょうとこの松葉杖が動きをバシッと検知するんで厳しいん
です判定がでこれで早くゴールに入ってすと勝
た以上移動だけで動く電子スクーターによりましてボールをゴールに入れるという
球技ですふぉ bar cross と言います
守る側はスティックで相手のボールを弾き飛ばす
まあなかなかこれも
やると熱くなるんですがこれけっこう練習が入ります練習いるんですけれどもこれは
結構子供の方が得意だったりしますね
a
初代チャンピオン子供が出るんじゃないかなと思っています
まあこのようなものを今あちこちで開発したり
展示をしたりしているというところでようやく始まったところなんですけれども
開発してみたらどんどん新しいアイディアが出てきましてそれを実現に動いていると
いうところであります
でこのようなスポーツというのは
次のビデオも見せしたいんですけどえっ他にも色々出てきてまして今回展示されなかっ
たものを1つだけ紹介しましょう
これですあのドローンて日本では首相官邸に起こしてから悪者扱いなんですが
スポーツ界ましょうたくさんドローンを飛ばして相手にぶつけるというと家ボール
危険な競技であります
ぜひこの大会を首相官邸前でやりたいという
こういうのを実際どこでやんのってのは大事なことでポイントでありまして
で実際にそのできる場所を
作っていきたいというのも我々のミッションであります
あの
超人スポーツを誘致できる2ジアム競技場のようなものを作ろうと思ってるんですが
これは超人スポーツと合わせて僕が進めているプロジェクトでして待て作ろうと思って
います
東京港区の竹芝というところにデジタルとコンテンツの集積特区を作ります it
iot ai がを集積した場所で長寿スポーツ
誘致したいと思ってまして2019年に街開きの予定でそこで
大会の開けたらなでこういったところで超人スポーツの研究開発とプレーヤーの育成
そして新しいスポーツビジネスの支援をしたいと思ってるんですが実はこの場所
首相からすでに国家戦略特区の認定をもらってまして長寿スポーツと
こう作ってんです道路交通法緩めてもらっていろんなことをやっちゃいかんことをやり
たい
電波特区に指定ですね超人スポーツ向けの電波の実験もやりたいし
ドローンレースもやりたいデジタルサイネージのトップにしまして屋外広告規制屋外
表示規制全部取っ払って超大画面のスクリーンをあちこちに置いて
超人スポーツみんなで楽しむなんてこともやりたいと思っています
まあそのような
ドキドキワクワクするようなことを超人スポーツやオリンピックぱーりんピックを
きっかけにして
この東京の場所からどんどんプロデュースしていきたいなぁと思っておりますので皆
さんも一緒にやりませんか
以上ですありがとうございました